if you break down your approach to chess
when you're at your best uh what what do
you think
what do you think contributes to that
approach is it memory recall specific
lines and positions is it intuition how
much of it is intuition how much of it
is pure calculation how much of it is
messing with the strategy of the
opponent so the game theory aspect in
terms of what contributes to the highest
level of play that um that you do I
think the answer
differs a little bit now from what it
did
eight years ago uh for instance like
I've I feel like I've had like two peaks
in in my career in 2014 uh well 2013
2014 and also it's in 2019 and in those
years I I was very different
um in terms of
um of my strength
strengths uh specifically in 2019 I
benefited a lot from opening preparation
uh while in 2013 2014 I mostly tried to
avoid my uh opponent's uh preparation
rather than that being a um being a
strength
so uh I'm mentioning that also because
it's something something you didn't um
didn't mention I think like my
intuitive understanding of Chess has
over those years
always been a little bit better than the
others even though it has
evolved as well
um certainly there are there are things
that I understand now that I didn't
understand
back then but that's not only for me
that's for
um for others as well
um I was younger back then so I played
with more energy which meant that I
could play better in long drawn out uh
games
um
which was also a necessity for me
because I didn't I couldn't couldn't
beat people in the in the openings
um but
in terms of calculation that's always
been a weird issue for me like I've
always been really really
um bad at solving exercises in chess
like
that's been
like a blind spot for me first of all I
found it hard to concentrate on them
um and to look
to look deep enough so this is like a
puzzle a position mate in X I mean one
thing is made but find the best move
that's generally the exercise like find
the best move find the best line you've
you just don't connect with it usually
like you have to to look look deep and
then when I get these lines during the
game I've very often find the
the right solution even though
um
even though I'm it's not still
um the best part of my game to to
calculate very
very deeply but it doesn't feel like
calculation you're saying in terms of no
it does sometimes but
for me it's more like I'm at the board
trying to find trying to find the
solution and I understand like the
training
at home is like trying a little bit to
to replicate that like you give somebody
half an hour
um in a position like in this instance
you might have thought for half an hour
if you play the game but I just I just
cannot do it uh one thing I know that I
am good at though is
um calculating short lines uh because I
calculate them them well I'm good at
seeing
um little details and I'm also
much better than than most at evaluating
uh which I think is something that sets
me uh sets me apart from from others so
evaluating specific position if I
if I make this move and the position
changes in this way
is this the step in the right direction
like in a big picture way yeah like you
calculate a few moves ahead and then you
evaluate because a lot of a lot of time
a lot of the times you cannot
um the branch just become so big that
you cannot calculate everything so you
have a fog yeah so you have to you have
to make evaluations based on you know
based mostly on knowledge and and
intuition and somehow I seem to do that
uh pretty well when you say you're good
at Short lines what's that what's what's
short that's usually like lines of um
two to four moves each okay so that
that's directly applicable to even
faster games like Blitz chess and so on
yeah
um Blitz as uh a lot about calculating
Force lines so those
you can see pretty clearly that the
players who struggle at Blitz who are
great at classical are those who rely on
a deep calculating ability because they
simply have don't have time for for that
templates you have to calculate quickly
and rely a lot on iteration